I'd love to hear all three of you
actually speak about any relationships
you may have had with the your real life
folks and how you how you cut the
difference between these real people and
the characters you're creating on screen
well it's tricky and as an actor it's a
challenge but it's a challenge that I
welcomed how do you get the essence of
somebody without caricaturing them and
so you have to work with your you have
to work with your director and in this
case Jamie Jamie had such a grip on this
story no by the way he's paying me for
this oh absolutely
he had such an American dollar this
story for many points of view not only a
director's point of view writers point
of view but historians point of view and
so you could really trust Jamie but the
question is okay we're playing I'm
playing somebody that's well-known on a
nightly basis and you got to be careful
how you're going to negotiate that and
so for me it was getting the essence of
something without being caricature and
and so as an actor and Dennis can
appreciate this in Kate that that's a
challenge that's it's good I mean it's
you want as an actor you want challenges
you know you want those things and this
was a challenge as an actor that I
welcome but it scared the hell out of me
what scared me was was representing
somebody on film that everybody knew at
one time on a nightly basis and how to
capture the essence of that person
without mimicking them and that was the
the thing in my advantage was that there
was 15 years in between when he was on
nightly news I mean it had this happened
in nineteen two thousand thirteen or
fourteen I I don't think I would have
touched it but the interesting thing
about Roger to me was he told the story
he was the he was the one who had been
to Vietnam and he was through him and
the stories he's telling it from the
perspective of someone who did not try
to get out of the draft who went there
for duty and love of country
and it just he was a little pissed off
hey the truth because of the way it the
story came out and he just wanted the
truth to come out and in that ten years
a lot has changed in journalism I
imagine your since watching this now it
feels almost like a requiem for a
certain period you know the death of the
anchor does it feel did how did the
script evolve over those ten years as
your sense of where journalism was
changing evolve did the script also
evolve the script a little bit but not
not as much maybe as you would think
because you know I always sort of
thought that the the best way to tell
the story was to tell the story and and
just to to you know one of one of the
the nice things that that Kate said when
we sort of started working on it was
that it's it's it's not a biopic it's a
story about a story and and these are
the people who worked on that story and
this is the experience they had on it so
I always sort of felt like the best way
to tell that was just to sort of drop
you into it
and to take you through what these
characters experienced was building the
story and then you know watching the the
wheels come off the bus and the story
sort of fall apart so in terms of that
it didn't change that much because it
was just about sort of giving the
audience that experience and that
experience didn't change between 2007
you know when I when I sort of both
first draft and now 2015 when the movie
came out so our perspective I think and
looking at it has changed and we're
looking at it through a different sort
of filter but the actual experience for
the characters and and what they went
through emotionally has always been the
same these stories about stories I kind
of laughed at Dennis's line this time in
a different way I didn't catch it the
first time we're just talking about all
it's all gonna be stories about how
journalism is made sure I'm sure that's
gonna happen we did was that sort of an
in-joke you put in the script well no
that was I mean you know one of the
wonderful things about you know making a
movie about real people is you can cheat
and you can actually talk to them and
and they'll they'll say wonderful things
about that so and and then you can go
I'm gonna write this down and have a
night so you know speaking to Roger
Colonel lieutenant Roger Charles you
know he sort of talked about that he
talked about you know we're going in
this you know we're getting to an echo
chamber type of place in terms of media
where it's you know someone reports a
story and somebody reports on that story
and then somebody reports on the
reporting of that story and it just kind
of pings around a little bit and I think
you know Colonel Charles was was correct
about that and that's sort of where we
are right now okay you and you and Bob
have such great and complicated
chemistry in this film it's paternal its
professional it's all kinds of different
things great in complicated chemistry
different directions you're off
reporting the story and he's on the
anchor desk and different rooms you got
a lot of phone calls happening in the
scene how did you build that chemistry
between the two of you to do there it is
we literally just came from having a
drink with Mary and and Dan and Dan plus
two and and still to this day you can
feel how symbiotically connected they
are both emotionally professionally and
psychologically and you know Mary will
turn to to Barb and say this is really
great for Dan and Dan will turn to me
and say thank you this has been so great
for Mary you know of care and respect
and an admiration between them and yes I
was excited to be working with Jamie
because you know with every single word
that was chosen within the script you
realized that there was a you know a
very short Oriole hand you know you know
at play there so that was a given but I
knew that the whoever I said well who'd
my foot my second question was who's
gonna play Dan because I knew that that
that the film would live or die on on
that connection when he said well my
first choice is Robert Redford and I
said well good luck
and then when I heard that bob was
interested I said well you know there's
anything I can do you know and when I
knew that that was you know a done deal
I I knew that that that we're on to
something really exciting and because
that is you know it's at the core of the
film that relationship and when you know
Kate being an actress and I am an actor
we're gonna go at something with some
research and so when I got this offer I
thought well I'm gonna call it dan
Rather and I called Dan and I said Dan I
looks like I'm gonna be playing you is
there anything you want to tell me about
this story he said yeah Bob it was
really about loyalty it was just about
loyalty my loyalty to Mary Mapes her
loyalty to me it was unbroken it was
unbroken royalty and that loyalty
enabled us to go through really really
ups and downs of difficult times and to
me that seemed to be the core of this
relationship which be the core of what
Jaime has written that what Kate and I
would try to bring to that with all the
other characters that Denis is involved
with it's about loyalty because you can
see in the film that all the characters
that that that play including Denis
because he was in a he was in a
difficult situation where he had to
leave one thing and support another
thing and yet he had a history of
military so so I felt that complexity
was really worth it but finally if you
boil it all down because you have to do
that yet today well what's it what's
finally this is all about it was about
loyalty and I thought that was a
wonderful core thing to work with yes
the film is incredibly specific it's
about a specific moment in time both for
an organization and you know a media
organization but and two individuals but
a better team of in you know individuals
but I think the film speaks to a far
greater unexamined of a series of events
and I think that that's what it reopens
you know what what was I found
remarkable and yes I knew that the bush
guard story but I didn't know about the
personal and professional detritus
afterwards and I feel like in a way why
what makes the film potential
compelling is that we haven't really
ants it got shut down so quickly in a
way that the Kerry Swift Boat stuff did
not you know and that in itself is an
interesting sort of question why did one
one examination get get shot down in
flames and another so-called examination
did not and and I think that there's
there's certain things that have not
been processed for all of us you know in
the way we've we digest information and
move on you know I think that that's
what what makes a film
I personally am not particularly
interested in agitprop you know pieces
of theater or film but but I'm
interested in films that that provoke
the conversation you know and I feel
like the conversation has been shut down
you know and and and and hopefully films
like this will kind of reignite it's
interesting that you know spotlight has
also come out of Toronto I think we're
interested in the way news gets
processed and disseminated and how
stories get built and who's behind those
stories I think I think and audiences
are quite sort of interested in that in
that process